hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
filter fume hoods expert insight on
improving your lab's green initiative
i am sabrina lemoos of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by lab conco
to learn more please visit www.lanco.com
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located on the top right of the
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speakers casey
fulmer and
the production specialist at laptonco
corporation
and kenneth crooks the director of green
fume hood technology at lebconko
corporation
for a complete biography on our speakers
please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
casey and kenneth welcome our speakers
will now begin their presentation
hello everyone and thank you for joining
us for this presentation on filtered
fume hoods and
improving your your lab screen
initiatives
uh with efficiency continuing to be a
point of
importance in building design and
operation one aspect of lab space as
often addressed first is the fume hood
as it can have a large effect on the
hvac
system let's first take a look at the
different types of fume hoods
that can be found in many lab spaces
the first that we'll look at are the
ducted
inductive fume hoods can come in one of
two
sort of configurations that would be
the remote blower or the built-in blower
models
and what we're going to discuss first is
going to be the
ducted hoods the first one that we're
going to talk about the first
configuration we're going to talk about
is going to be the remote blower
configuration
this is the most uh most common type of
installation this puts the blower on
the roof or somewhere outside the
building away from
the the fume hood in a remote location
um hence the hence the type of
configuration
that is that is titled here this also
allows it to be a little bit quieter
than typical because as i've as i've
said it's it's far away from the hood
another aspect to the remote blower is
that it can be
sized for duct length this includes
the total length of the duct the uh the
the 90 degree
bends or any other sort of uh
differences in your mechanical system
the benefit here is that
no matter what you have this this can be
properly sized
for a blower that's going to work for
your individual
uh fume hood setup they are
also um they're also very safe
remote blower puts the entire duct run
under negative pressure
and that means that if there are any
leaks or or
seams in the duct run
all the air on the outside of the duct
is just going to be stuffed into the
duct
and then exhausted through through the
building so you're not at
risk of any contaminants getting into a
lab space
with a with a remote blower having a
duct system
under negative pressure
next you can also uh challenge the
blower with a damper
this typically goes between the the fume
hood
and the blower um and that
allows the the system to be able to be
balanced easier
and ensure that the blower is operating
within its with when it within its
most optimal range
this is the setup of a typical setup of
a remote blower
you can see the zero pressure weather
cap that's on the top
that does two things it allows you to
reach
important height requirements or
discharge
for building codes as well as prevents
moisture or
precipitation from uh getting into the
blower and
in causing problems in in that sense so
that's just what they typically look
like i wanted to make sure i showed that
picture because
it's pretty beneficial to see this uh
see this setup
so next we're going to talk about the
built-in blower configure configuration
these are for simple economical
situations
and they're ideal for short straight
duck runs in low toxicity applications
this is because it puts the blower right
on top of the fume hood
instead of on top of the building where
there's there's a lot of bends and
connections that need to be made
between the two they are generally
noisier
than remote blower installations as i've
said this
is a situation where it puts the blower
right at the outlet of the fume hood
instead of really far away with a remote
blower that means you hear the blower
a lot better in this type of situation
the major downfall of a built-in blower
configuration
is the ductwork is under positive
pressure
so in in contrast to the remote blower
situation if there's a leak
or in a theme or or a crack in the
ductwork
the the comp the components the the
hazardous material that
is being dealt with in the future is
actually going to be pushed
out of those themes and into the lab
space
so that's why um all of this is is for
very
simple situations and setups because
um this it's not the safest uh
situation and straight duck runs uh are
a great way to eliminate
that type of um that type of risk
so here are the associated costs with
with
abducted fume hoods and it mainly comes
in the form of the mechanical systems
this includes the ductwork itself
the exhaust fans the supply air
because if you are exhausting here you
need to make sure that you are supplying
enough air
so that the blower is is able to do its
job and
is not starved of air and as well as the
installation
so there is a lot that goes into the
ducted fume hoods that
that really need to be thought of on on
the front end of
the design phase and can
can cause some additional costs in the
in the build
so that was ducted fume hoods and the
other uh
the other form of humans that we're
going to talk about are the ductless
fume hoods
and these come in three types you have
the dh1
the dh2 and the dh3 setups
the duct dose enclosures as the haste
sound have no duct which is a great
benefit
and how they are able to do this is
through carbon filtration
so these these filters they capture
the the chemicals that are being brought
through them and
are able to recirculate clean air into
the lab space
most of the time your application will
need to be reviewed by the manufacturer
or someone of someone involved in that
to
make sure that it is applicable to what
you're doing in the lab
because not every application is is
suited for this i mean it's not a
substitute for
every hood there are a lot of benefits
that come with a ductless enclosure or
ductless fume hood
and one of them would be energy
efficient
as i've stated before the duck or ducted
fume hoods
will take air out of a building that has
been tempered to
to the comfort level of the lab and is
exhausting it out of the air
or out of the lab space then
air has to be supplied into the lab so
untempered air
has to be brought into the lab space
all of this takes money and to make sure
that uh the lab space and the air the
temperature the humidity all of it is
remains constant with these ducted hoods
no air is exhausted so that is benefit
in that
it doesn't have as big of a a burden or
doesn't present
as a big bigger burden on an hvac system
the next benefit is that they are
environmentally friendly
so ducted hood ducted hoods will take
the these chemicals
and hazardous vapors and fumes and
they'll exhaust them into the atmosphere
with the ductless enclosure you're
capturing those and then you're
you're taking these filters that have uh
that are that have been loaded with
these
hazardous materials and then you're
disposing of them
in a in an environmentally friendly way
next benefit is that they are very
flexible
they offer um flexible installation
uh they are able to be put in in
the the bottom building or the bottom
room of a very tall building where duct
work does not seem
plausible they're able to be put in a
building that is very
old and adding new infrastructure to the
buildings it would seem
very expensive and very labor intensive
so this added dimension of flexibility
is is a very big benefit of these these
ducted
fume hoods or ductless spheres
as i've mentioned before there are
different types of
ductless hoods and that's in there dh
this is defined by fifa 9 and we're
going to talk about the
the different dhs the dh1 the dh2 and
the dh3s next
first we're going to start with the dh1
the dh1
is is it has a filter it has a carbon
filter
but it's mainly for non-toxic or
nuisance odors
these also do not have a chemical sensor
so pretty much with a dh1
a ductless hood one anything that you
could do on an open bench
you can do in this hood things like
cover slipping or staining
so it's a very simple application that
these are these are designed for
next we have the dh2 hood or ductwork
hood
2. this hood meets all of the dh1
requirements
plus it has different types of filters
like in organic filters or ammonia
filters or
or different kinds of filters that you
can order based on what your application
requires
they can also handle manufacturer
approved toxic chemicals
often determined through a chemical
assessment form
another thing about the dh2 is that they
do have a
chemical sensor to detect breakthrough
unlike the dh1
these are not typical fume hoods though
as you can as you can kind of see
the sash here the opening just lifts up
instead of rising vertically and
seamlessly
there's also no room for service
fixtures such as
air gas electrical or anything that you
might need for the fuel
finally we will talk about the dh3
or the ductless hood 3. now this hood
meets
all of the dh2 requirements plus
and this is a big one it has a secondary
backup filter
and in particular the secondary filter
is identical
to the primary filter where the dh2
lacks in safety is that if you are using
the hood
and the the chemical breakthrough sensor
goes off
well you don't have a whole lot of time
to to clear out everything that's in the
hood
once that chemical sensor is going off
there's potential that that
chemical or that vapor is ex or escaping
into the lab space
with the dh3 it has a secondary filter
so even if that that alarm goes off you
still have your secondary backup filter
that will protect you for as long as it
takes to
decontaminate the hood or just get
everything out
and then ultimately replace the filters
these filters are of one kind and they
are built to handle acid solvents and
bases
so again the difference here between the
dh3 and the dh2 is that the dh3 just
offers a new dimension
of versatility in that you don't need to
buy
multiple types of filters you're good
with the one
which is which is a big benefit these
hoods are also
the closest thing to a ducted general
chemistry
hood without being ducted to outside of
course these as you can see in the
picture it is a full-size hood
the sash raises vertically instead of
hinges and there's also
there's also slots on the corner post
that allow for the installation
of service fixtures such as the air gas
and
electrical
so now i wanted to go over a cost
analysis of different types of fume hood
configurations that will allow you to
decide
what is best for my lab the first one i
want to talk about is conventional fume
hood
or a constant air volume situation
this is a this is a scenario where the
quantity of the
quantity of the exhaust air never
changes hence the name
constant air volume no matter where the
sash is
or the the components inside the hood
you're always exhausting the same amount
of air
for this situation or for this analysis
we're going to use
a specific exhaust volume of about 1200
cfm
this is pretty typical for a
conventional six foot bench top fume
hood
the initial cost on this would include
the
the fume hood itself as well as the
building infrastructure
the mechanical electrical and plumbing
and we're going to take a look at this
in a in a in a table
format you can see here the bench top
hood
itself is about fourteen thousand five
hundred dollars
the building infrastructure adds on
another twenty thousand dollars
and then that which means the the total
capital equipment cost
is about thirty four thousand five
hundred dollars
out of all of the systems that we're
going to look at this is actually the
lowest
uh the lowest initial cost of of the
three
but you'll notice uh where it where it
has a low initial cost it makes up for
in the operating and maintenance costs
specifically
the makeup air column of having
nine thousand six hundred dollars it's a
pretty large number
and equates to about twelve thousand one
hundred and sixty seven dollars
a year of operating and maintenance
costs
for that one hood it's a pretty
significant
cost especially when you see what the
next couple of hoods will bring
the next analysis that we're going to do
is on a variable air volume fume hood
as the name suggests the uh the vav
means that the quantity of the exhaust
air actually changes to maintain a
specific
base velocity so in the cav what
remains constant is the air exhausted
and if vav what remains exhaust
what remains constant is the phase
velocity
and in this situation a typical six foot
bench top fume hood
will be able to operate on about 800
cfm average the initial cost for
this type of fume hood includes the
diffuse itself
very similar to the cav as well as the
building infrastructure
and finally it requires vav integration
with a with a whole nother system
this dud this does add a little bit more
of initial cost as you'll see in this
table
we can see a comparison here between the
constant volume
and the variable air volume fumehood in
that it does have
a larger initial cost um
at the 39 500 about 5 000
more where it makes up for that
is going to be in the operating
maintenance cost
and again drawing attention to the
makeup
air portion of this table it only
requires about
six thousand four hundred dollars and
this number
comes from taking about um a typical
cost for a fume hoods as per cfm
is about eight dollars per cfm
per year and that's where we're getting
these makeup air
numbers and the viv overall has about a
operating maintenance cost per year of
eight thousand eight hundred and eleven
dollars
so there are significant yearly cost um
savings by by going to a variable air
volume system
and last we're going to look at the echo
filter beam hud this is
this is a ductless ductless
fume hood that we've sort of discussed
and
in these hoods air is filtered and then
it's recirculated into the room
this means that the exhaust volume is 0
cfm much less the initial costs are are
very similar
in that you do need the fume hood but
where these hoods differ
is that you need to order the these
filters that go with the fume hood
they are a separate cost
i wanted to look at a final cost
analysis with all three of these
put in one slide you can see that the
the total cost uh total capital
equipment cost for the
echo filter fume hood is actually less
than that of the variable air volume
hood at 38 520
approximately where this hood
really excels is in that makeup air
portion it has zero dollars
per year since you're recirculating air
in in in that eight dollars per cfm
does not apply here it does have a
little bit higher of maintenance costs
per year because
um you do have the filters associated
with the fume hood
but that 2093 dollars
of total operating and maintenance costs
per year
more than makes up for that so
that is that is the those are the the
types of fume hoods and
in ways that you can you can explore to
see what kind of uh ways you can
increase your
your labs efficiency but i wanted to
pass this on to to ken crooks with erlab
to explain
how these filtered fume hoods are able
to do what they do
and and perform the way that they are
all right thank you very much casey good
job appreciate that
so uh and thank you all to our viewers
uh for your time today appreciate that
too
so we look at the filtration and we want
to know you know how does it work
obviously it's very important it's
pretty pretty simple how abducted fume
hood works but how does a ductless hood
especially a dh3
the best of the best here so i just want
to work logically
this is a module or stack of filtration
technology sitting on top of
the filtered fume hood and starting at
the bottom you first off have
a light you know the hood users need to
see what they're doing of course
and then above that light will be some
pre-filters there are optional different
pre-filters we'll talk about that in a
couple slides
and then on top of that base module
would be a hepa filter
if you're working with hazardous powders
this is not required this is optional
and if you're not working with any
hazardous particulates or solids that
may become particulates
or high temperature acid use then you
would not need the hepa filter and i'll
talk about how we determine
when and where on top of that would be
the first carbon filter so this is the
one
i like to describe as doing all the
heavy lifting this is doing the chemical
adsorption
day in and day out capturing everything
generated within that hood
and stopping it at that point coming off
the outlet side of this filter
will be very clean air and i'll talk
about just how clean in a minute
amazingly clean on top of that now would
be the fan box and so
just like casey was describing with the
remote blower configuration
or the manifolded vav system that has
the hood up on the roof also
this fan i'm sorry has the fan up on the
roof also this fan
is drawing air in through the open sash
up through the cavity of the fume hood
capturing whatever is being evaporated
and vapors and what not used inside that
hood
and then drawing it up through the
filtration column
so again any leakage would be clean air
into dirty not contaminated air blowing
out i mean it's a very important point
and of course we comply with that also
and then lastly
sitting on the very top of this is that
safety filter so after the fan
and detection area that's also where the
sensors are located we place a redundant
fully redundant
safety filter on top so once we detect
molecular breakthrough of the primary
filter
and we sound that alarm down to the user
we also have that secondary safety
filter sitting on top to capture
whatever molecules did break through
and still return clean air back into
that laboratory
very important differentiation with the
dh3 technology
so how does it all look this is a six
foot wide fume hood you can see
if you count there's four modules of
filtration stacked up in there
and so this is our latest generation of
technology
and we're very excited to release this
with labconco and our goals were to
improve the filtration capacity for
solvents
solvents and i have a slide coming up on
that solvents are the most
challenging chemical you can use they're
also the most common but we've got that
figured out not to worry
secondly ease of integration and
installation and so this lower image
here where the three
base modules are in descending order
there they basically are i have kids
you'll realize when i say this they're
like
legos they interlock and they stack and
they distribute power and communications
both horizontally and vertically
and self-configure so that was a huge
step in the right direction
for ease of integration and installation
for our dealers and making sure that you
the customer
are handed over a fully working filtered
fume hood
next up we wanted to improve the
detection by adding more sensors so
there's now an optional formaldehyde
sensor
especially with the new safety limits on
formaldehyde exposure it was very
important to get a
specific sensor for that for the
applications that are using formaldehyde
you don't need it if you're not
also a relative humidity sensor in each
fan module
and the temperature sensor was already
there but we've now moved it up into
each
fan module also and then lastly adding
an anemometer
so we'll measure directly the face
velocity and so that's the speed of
which that air is moving into
the fume hood it's a very good indicator
of safety though
containment testing is the final
indicator of that
we wanted to expand the communications
so you can still hardwire to your
building network
my kids back to them again my kids look
at me cross-eyed when i say hard-wired
no come on now so we have wi-fi and
bluetooth capabilities also
so much easier connectivity there and
then the configuration and flexibility
there are different pre-filters you can
use
along with different sensors you can use
depending on your specific application
but as casey had also mentioned earlier
there's that one filter type that
handles acids
bases and solvents simultaneously in
much higher volumes than in the past
and simplified the maintenance also of
course with these improvements now it's
much easier to maintain these hoods
it was pretty easy before but it's a lot
easier even now
so i mentioned solvents that first goal
we don't have to go through all these
details i don't want to bore you with
these but again
solvents because of their volatile
nature have always been the largest
challenge
with chemical molecular filtration
activated carbon type filters and so
we've done a few patented things here
that have really expanded our capacity
the example graph here is ethanol we've
increased it over 600 percent
uh the time before some level of
emission is sensed
after the filter and the first column on
the graph on the left
i guess no sorry middle column the one
percent of
tlv threshold limit value so that is a
value of
exposure that's allowed by the american
council of governmental industrial
hygienists
and tlv is not a short-term exposure it
is a lifetime exposure so eight hours a
day
five days of work week 40 years of your
life we're guaranteeing to you
detection and alarming at no greater
than one percent of that already very
low limit
and so how that plays in here to our
capacity these are capacity increases
before we sense
greater than one percent on the outlet
side of the primary filter
so just a real dramatic increase is
there still room for improvement heck
yeah if you're going to use diethyl
ether or cyclohexane
those are challenging and we'll want to
use those with
really a focus on limiting evaporation
so very very small amounts
and keep the capped and covered when
you're not using it because it's got a
low boiling point it wants to evolve
very quickly
i think you know that if you use them so
sensation
sensors and detection how is it we go
about that that one percent tlv exposure
that i just talked about
so first off there's an acid sensor in
there a whole suite of sensors
and a solvent sensor that are both
located up in the fan modules
so when that primary filter is no longer
at the efficiency that we all want it to
be at
we will detect that and we will alarm
meanwhile coming back into that
laboratory is
clean air no greater than one percent of
what you're allowed to be exposed to so
it could be 99 and you'd still be safe
our guarantee to you
is less than one percent of that just to
be extra safe
additionally we have that optional
formaldehyde sensor we expect that to be
in about 15 percent of the applications
not too commonly used but when it is
it is and then that temperature and
humidity sensor also
and lastly that anemometer sensor all of
these add up to
safety if we're sensing it we're
detecting it
that's going to bring to you safety as a
hood user
but we need to know how you're going to
use these hoods as casey talked
i think very early on this isn't for
everybody
ductless hoods need to be approved each
and every time for your specific
application
so any reputable manufacturer will come
to you with a chemical questionnaire
and this is a lot more than just a
chemical list chemical list is a good
sort of go no-go gauge place to start
but we need to better understand
not only which chemicals you're using
but how you're using them what is the
type of handling in this case we have a
couple recrystallizations some
evaporation
thin layer chromatography so forth and
so on then you tell us the chemical you
tell us what type of container it's
going to be housed in that
lets us know how much evaporation may
happen when it's open you tell us is it
primarily open or closed
what's the dilution or concentration the
temperature vitally important to know
the temperature you're handling that
chemical at
how often do you do that handling on
average per month across a year
and then each time that you handle it
how many milliliters or grams depending
if it's a liquid or solid
and then for how long and so armed with
this level of information and detail
which
is a little bit of a work for your hood
users to complete but once it's done
it's done
we can go through there and be
absolutely sure that your application is
either approved or denied
and we typically deny about 30 25 to 30
percent of the applications each year
and if we don't approve it we won't let
it be sold it's really just that simple
safety first and then that report and
that approval
will go through everything provided by
the hood users and we'll from a safety
perspective
at the very top of this slide we'll look
at containment is everything you
declared to be used in this hood
going to be contained by the hood now
this doesn't matter if it's ducted or
ductless
in this case we're just looking at what
is it you're using
and an important part of this also is
just making sure that everybody knows to
be crystal clear this
is a chemical fume hood this is not a
biosafety cabinet
sometimes we say filtered people start
to think of bsc a biosafety cabinet
which is also hepa filtered for
biologicals
biologicals are not approved for use in
these hoods so we'll we'll double check
that on the chemical list
detection is everything declared it's
going to break through those filters
will
we be able to detect it will the filter
then be compatible with everything
on that list will we capture and contain
everything on that list
and then lastly life expectancy which
approval of that is really more
up to the end users so on that point in
the middle here under the filtration
section is filter life now a little a
little internal speak
sorry for this the m1 through m6 that's
the hood size going from a three footer
up to an eight footer so for example an
m4
four modules of filtration that is a six
foot wide hood very common application
in undergraduate chemistry teaching labs
for instance our our most prevalent
application
and in that case we're guaranteeing for
this customer 48 months filter life
very typical for what we see again
especially in teaching applications
if the hepa filters are required we'll
check that off if the acid
and ammonia pre-filter options are
required we'll check those off
individually or as shown here together
it really depends on which chemicals
you're using and how we can maximize the
overall
neutron filter life and and your safety
so that's where the different
pre-filters that configurability we
talked about earlier
comes into play and then lastly based on
your specific application we will
fine-tune
the sensitivity of the breakthrough
detectors the solvent sensors and the
acid sensors
just making those appropriate for the
hazards or lack of hazard
of the chemicals you're using in that
hood
when we look at how we know all this i
mean how is it that one company can
can know all this information we've been
doing it for over 50 years we have our r
d lab over in france
this is just a quick picture of it not
to brag i just want to say this is the
level to which we go
we've got filtered storage cabinets
ductless hoods the filtration technology
that lab conco uses on their filtered
fume hoods
ceiling mounted fan filter units we know
filtration it's
what we do and then in the middle of
that back there is a little bubble our
test chamber i'll talk about that in a
moment
so when i talk about the go no go the
chemical list
we have two different lists the short
list is the no go list if you will
and so these are chemicals that are not
retained well by
any type of carbon filtration and the
best way to look at that is they have
low boiling points and low molecular
weights
therefore the gaseous at standard
temperature and pressure
and this list is basically what you
would expect hydrogen
all the noble gases methane ethane
carbon monoxide carbon dioxide nitrogen
monoxide you can read
sox nox and so these are the most common
gaseous chemicals now the good news is
they're not commonly used
in laboratories and some of these aren't
even hazardous not in the concentration
that would be released
into the laboratory but some of them
most certainly are so if you're using
any of these and you're using them in
higher volumes
it's probably a no go for filtered fume
hood if you're using them in lower
volumes and i know higher and lower
that's always a difficult subject what
is high what is low what is a lot what
is a little what is medium
really depends on the frequency and the
quantity used i like to think of if it's
less than 200 milliliters a couple times
a month
i think we've got something i think
we've got a solution for you however the
real point is
your environmental health and safety
officer definitely needs to be involved
because we're going to look at what will
happen
if those chemicals and again it's only
these chemicals would be released into
the lab how quickly would they be
diluted and removed from that lab
through the ventilation
again the good news is not commonly used
at all and from our experience which is
great
now it's not just the chemicals it's
also which applications are not
recommended for a filtered fume hood i
mean this again this is the no go list
right so if you're a perchloric acid
hood if you're a radioisotope hood or
acid digestion type hood
definitely stick with your ducted hood
that's a special build a special part
anyhow
it is not a candidate for filtration
highly exothermic reactions one thing to
remember about filtered ductless
hoods is they do not remove heat from
the laboratory
so unlike a ducted hood which would it
would exhaust that heat right outside
filter hoods would not they would return
that heat right to the lab itself
again really not a problem for your
teaching
uh classes you're usually working with
smaller amounts you can absolutely use
bunsen burners and
in these hoods and and uh you know heat
your samples and whatnot
that's not a problem it's just that if
it's a really exothermic type reaction
especially if it generates a lot of
smoke also with that carbon filters do
not capture smoke
the optional hepa filters will capture
most smoke particles
i think there would still be a slight
smoke odor that would make it into the
lab though
so these are again things to consider on
the on the no go list
mercury not commonly used anymore
thankfully uh we can capture it really
well problem is we can't detect it so we
put that on the no go list
not down at the tlv level required
anyhow and then anything that's
high toxicity or basically immediately
lethal those would not be used in a
filtered fume hood
all right so then how do we know that
again getting down to the nitty-gritty
here
so we have our our test bubble here in
the back of our laboratory in france
and we have our gcms machine and we have
gone through hundreds of chemicals the
most commonly used chemicals in
laboratories today
and those 700 plus chemicals represent
thousands of chemicals that'll respond
in a very similar manner to
molecular adsorption activated carbon
molecular absorption
and each one of those is tested at least
six or more
different concentrations and then each
one of those individual tests
is performed twice just a minimum twice
just to make sure
repeatability so we're absolutely
confident in our
capacity charts and we know exactly how
much we're going to capture
before you're going to have uh greater
than one percent
tlv uh breakthrough on that filter
and then again they represent thousands
of different chemicals
not every chemical and so if you've got
a chemical that's not on our long list
we absolutely can review that and even
test that in this chamber in our
laboratory
so that's the test bubble that's the
gcms which is no great deal everybody
knows that it's just a
very large investment for us in testing
instruments but very much required
and so with that and with all that
testing for now decades of testing
we have published our latest edition of
the long list this is the chemical list
that is now over 60 pages long
of the chemicals that we know exactly
how much we can adsorb
and from that we'll know how long the
filter will last in your specific
application
maintenance casey talked about how in
his slide about eighteen hundred dollars
per year is the average operating cost
and that is replacing the filters
uh maintaining the the system make sure
it's working year after year
so it's not makeup air that's the great
thing because that's much more expensive
and so when it comes time to replace the
filter it's a very easy system we call
it a revolving system
i wish it were a crank handle and it
would revolve on its own it's not quite
that simple
you do have to lift off the old filter
and put the new one on but not a big
deal it's 25 pounds the top of a six
foot ladder
at arm's length easy to do
and so the first thing you want to do
obviously is wear your standard ppe
gloves
glasses if required in your lab a lab
coat too
absolutely not a problem there you do
not need to wear a respirator that is
not required
once the chemical is adsorbed by the
carbon bed it is staying in there the
molecules are not coming out you could
lift the filter off accidentally drop it
on the floor from again the top of that
six foot ladder
and it won't but if you managed to break
it open we have it
compartmentalized so it wouldn't do that
but if you managed to break it open
somehow
you'd have carbon granules on the floor
it'd be quite a mess to sweep up no big
deal i've never done it in seven years
but again could be done
what you wouldn't have most importantly
is you wouldn't have liquid chemicals
you wouldn't have escape of molecules
they're all
in that carbon structure held there not
to be released
not under normal atmospheric conditions
anyhow
so you would then take the secondary
filter the one that's on top that safety
filter
move it down to the primary position so
it can start doing all the heavy lifting
as i call it
step two you would put a new secondary
filter on top
and then step three you would package
the old primary filter
in the heavy poly bag and cardboard box
that the new filter came in
and send that off for environmental
disposal and there's a couple things
there
easiest and simplest most direct is out
for high temp incineration as hazardous
waste
the good news is carbon filters have a
lot of embedded energy
coconut shells activated coconut shells
is what we use as our
as our medium and the best on earth 15
000
square feet of surface area per gram all
of that is absorbed chemicals now you
have a lot of embedded energy that the
incinerator will put back up on the
electric grid
to the tune of around 78 kilowatts per
filter
i mean tremendous energy back up on the
grid from each one of these filters
and what comes out of that per epa
requirements you must have a 99.99
efficient incinerator is basically one
molecule on a 10 000
gets out into the atmosphere up the
stack there'll be some co2 there'll be
some water molecules but one in ten
thousand molecules of chemical make it
up
versus ten thousand of every ten
thousand on the ducted hood
that you didn't use uh when you chose
the filtered hood
there is an option to do the t-clip or
tclp
and testing to make sure nothing leeches
from these filters and then the filters
can go out as
standard household waste that testing is
expensive though so you'd have to have a
lot of filters at the same time
and that's worked for some of our
customers just throwing that out there
as an option
and then obviously because now the fan
has also been removed and put back in
place the filters have been changed and
rotated
you need to recertify that hood filtered
hoods just like ducted hoods just like
ductless hoods
should be annually re-certified and
that's through a third-party independent
company
with no stake in the game whatsoever
they come in they read face velocity
they make sure
you're running a safe hood at that
operating sash operating height that
you've
previously dictated
when you look at the absolute best
benefit of using filtered fume hoods it
is the 20-year operational carbon
footprint there is a 94 reduction
and many thanks to br plus a consulting
engineers in boston for doing the
research here
looking at everything from transporting
the carbon to making the filters to
incinerating everything after the fact
to the metal work that goes into a
ducted hood versus a filter hood
same metal cabinets same lab concocture
but avoiding as you can see in orange
and red
avoiding most of that electricity cost
and all of the gas cost
if you're in a zone that needs to reheat
you will see a very large reduction
in the carbon footprint so when it's
safe to use for your application which
each application must be blessed ahead
of time
there is a tremendous environmental and
monetary
benefit to using the filtered fume hood
all right casey i think it is
back to you now thanks dan
appreciate you providing that
information so by now
you've learned what a duct ductless fume
hood is
you've learned about the the benefits
that it can have
on on an hvac system and improving the
efficiency of your of your facility
and you've also learned about how um
how it is how it works and how it's safe
but now let's talk about what lab congo
has to offer
in in these types of uh these types of
products
first we have our echo which is a
full-size sphere hood
as i have mentioned before it comes in
multiple widths
it comes in it comes in configurations
that has
no windows it has side windows which is
what is shown here
and it also has side and back windows
that allows for a 360 degree
view of a hood interior which is great
for teaching up uh teaching
applications um we also have a smaller
more compact version of the echo in our
arrow
it has a shallower depth and also comes
in shower
shallower widths i mean it's also a
little bit shorter so it provides a
a good option for situations where
maybe you have a smaller footprint on in
your lab space or
you have reduced height in your ceiling
but still need a
a ductless new hood to operate your
applications inside of
there's also a an echo floor mounted
fume hood
which is very unique it's a
one-of-a-kind fume hood and it's
and it is completely ductless um and it
comes in
in multiple widths the same width as the
the echo benchtop but also comes in
two additional depths because these
hoods are made to be
they're made to house large pieces of
equipment
so there are a lot of different sizes
in in shapes to make meet your uh
your application needs um so that's what
live concord has to offer
um but i want to talk about the process
of
uh of going about getting a ductless
beam hood
the first step that needs to be done is
a an lpq
or chemical assessment needs to be
filled out as
as i have mentioned in this ken has
mentioned this is
a very important step because it
determines the filtration compatibility
and the requirements there are certain
things that they can add that we can add
to
the the filtration column that can
maybe handle a certain part of your
application um
and ultimately make sure that uh the
longevity of these
filters and the safety of the operator
are insured
and next you need to identify the
appropriate hood and as i mentioned in
the previous slide
left conco has a variety of sizes of
fumes
so in identifying this you'll need to
take into account the size of equipment
that you're that you may be using or the
available space that you have in your
facility
and ensure that you are uh selecting the
proper theme hood for for your
application
next uh most bench top uh fume hoods or
all all bench top
fume hoods need somewhere to sit and
that's where a work surface would come
in place
uh something to take into account would
be a besides in
in a sink location if you're using water
and need to dispose of it
that would be something that you should
take into account um and then finally
to specify any service fixture
requirements that you have whether
that's water air gas electrical
vacuum uh pretty much anything that that
you need to put in your hood you need to
make sure that you're you're having
accounted for
so that's what we have for for the the
filtered fume hoods in
improving your labs green initiative i
appreciate you taking the
time to listen to this presentation and
and i hope i hope you can take something
away from us and i look forward to
answering any and all of your questions
thank you
thank you so much casey and ken for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions
as we have time for our first question
what is the average lifespan for a set
of filters
so the average lifespan it definitely
depends on
the application but we found that it's
it ranges from about two to five years
uh five being the max and and two
typically being the minimum so it's in
that range
is where they will will typically uh
fall in longevity
wonderful and the next question i have
what kind of spaces can filtered hoods
be utilized
uh in in pretty much any space uh
there's often times a a good good mix of
ducted
and duct less fume hoods for an
individual lap space but
but where these ones are more more
versatile or
are like modular labs or temporary
spaces
if if say you're moving into a new lab
and you have a
uh like a lab space outside that's in a
trailer or something that you you still
need to perform your
your applications and your procedures in
they
they are they're great for that as well
since they can be moved
into the permanent lab space after it's
finished
yeah i agree and i'll just jump in there
if you don't mind
the the swing space is is quite a need
right now with
uh renovations and new construction in
um education facilities
and that's been a really good
application for these hoods also for for
exactly all the reasons casey just said
um so definitely think of them for that
and if you've got
an application that is understood
repeatable a certain level of
administrative controls
also help this is an engineered solution
but you do need
administrative controls when it comes to
a filtered hood
that's again why i think the education
marketplace higher ed is our number one
application
thank you so much for that okay the next
one i have coming in
says the dh3 have baffled in the back
and if not um how are we dealing with
the issue of airflow around
objects on the work surface
that's a that's a great question and one
that needs to be asked
asked so no they do not have uh
have baffles in them and that's actually
by design so what does a baffle do
is it draws draws the air back away from
the sash
and and then up well
that would actually load the uh the
filters
uh in the back in in risk
the uh the sensors going off uh before
they're
they're able to and ken can confirm that
uh for me if you can but
um to expand on this is that these hoods
even without the baffle have been put
through a modified ashrae test
uh in in that modified ashrae test they
use
um the isoprops isopropyl alcohol
in uh in and they still
have very low detection limits which is
showing that the hoods are still
containing even without the baffles
so yeah i'll jump in thanks casey
exactly right and and
even and so that's the modified so
testing in the field because
sf6 or nox the typical tracer gas is now
in place even though
ashrae is changing that the sf6 nox
they will go through the filter and
invalidate the test results so
we've got that modified test procedure
for in the field at the factory the fume
wood manufacturers do a full and
complete 110 test
you know they attach a duct to the top
of it where the filters are and exhaust
that
tracer gas so that it doesn't invalidate
the results and
correct we pass amazingly well without
the baffles in the back
the thing to remember here is instead of
trying to cram all that air through a 10
inch duct collar
somewhat centered in the top of the hood
the almost entire
surface of the ceiling of the fume hood
is the exhaust port
those multiple stacks i showed an
example of a six footer with four
filtration columns
those multiple stacks are columns
modules of filtration
draw the air up certainly not laminar
flow not technically anyways the
reynolds number's not 2000 but
in a in a nearly linear fashion and we
get a much better flow coming in and up
and through and out
so much more reliable actually than
trying to put it all through a 10 inch
duct collar
which can be done and you guys have
solved that problem too
good question thank you
wonderful thanks so much for your
informative answers and thank you to the
audience for
and for asking these great questions the
next one i have
is what climate is your makeup air costs
how
calculated in
so that's that's also a good question
because that number will fluctuate based
on
where the the hoods are installed uh
what we have found is that
the uh so that calculation is done on
about
eight dollars per cfm and
uh what we have found the range is about
five dollars to about thirteen dollars
per uh per cfm
depending on where you're at so um it is
a
an estimate number but it's kind of in
the middle of what we've we've
uh we've seen to to kind of give as
accurate as a number as we could
wonderful the next one are the new
generation filters compatible with
the previous units sure i'll jump on
that one there
so unfortunately the answer that is no
we to
embrace a lot of the new technology and
the new approach we really had to
sort of cut the umbilical cord if you
will so there is no backwards
compatibility to the existing filtered
fume hoods
we'll still make the filters to
obviously support those customers for
the life of those hoods out there
there's
thousands of them at this point but we
needed to really take a giant
technological leap forward
and that required that we could not hold
backwards compatibility we love to
and that's always a goal on all of our
new products however we just
couldn't do that in this case thank you
very good question
wonderful thank you again casey and ken
for your time today
and your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor la pronco
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of your registration this
webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until then
stay healthy and safe until next time
goodbye